Transcriptor: Sebastian Betti
Este es mi cuarto.
Mi templo.
Podría ser tu cuarto.
Tu templo.
O el de cualquier niño o niña
de cualquier lugar del mundo.
¿Por qué un templo?
Porque es sagrado.
Porque en tu cuarto
se crean mundos.
Yo acá creé mi mundo.
Y hoy les vine a contar cómo encajé
mi mundo en el mundo.
Que a veces es donde se complica un poco.
Empieza cuando sos chiquito, tu cuarto,
empezás a escuchar, a ver, a pensar,
a sentir.
Empezás a desarrollar lo que para mí
es el superpoder de los humanos,
que es la imaginación
y la proyección propia.
El verse, el sentirse, el imaginarse
en donde uno quiere estar.
Uno empieza a ver películas de tipo
Spiderman
y los chiquitines flashean
que va a salir la tela de araña...
me acuerdo mucho que
me gustaba mucho Hulk
y sentía que en cualquier momento
me iba a poner verde.
Y eso es poderoso.
Uno empieza a probar cosas.
Y yo me crucé primero con el skate.
Me encantaba...
Me encantaba lo urbano de muy chiquito
y mi mamá me llevaba siempre
al skate park.
Le pedía y me dijo “Si querés mejorar,
juntarte con los que lo hacen bien”.
Así que yo de una siempre fui,
encaré a los skater profesionales
que estaban ahí.
Me llevaba... con el que veía que sacaba
fotos, me llevaba re piola.
Era un chiquitín que andaba siempre ahí
con los más grandes porque los admiraba.
Pero me costó un poco trascender
en el skate, que fue como mi primer
proyección personal,
que era ser skater profesional
porque me daba un poco de miedo
hacer ciertas pruebas porque,
bueno, es un deporte extremo
y no pude trascender en el deporte.
Pero también me di cuenta de que
si me hubiese gustado de una manera
muy, muy pasional este mundo del skate,
no está solo el skater profesional.
Además del skater pro tenés
el que saca las fotos pro,
el que diseña las tablas pro,
el que diseña las zapas pro,
el que las vende.
Entonces hay muchos mundos en un mundo,
si hubiese querido trascender
en ese mundo.
Pero, bueno, sos chiquitito
y seguís probando otros mundos.
Se me cruzó un mundo muy lindo.
El de la historieta, los cómics.
Ahí me puse un poco más en el cuarto,
a dibujar un montón, me había flasheado
cómo inventan los universos tipo Marvel.
Dije, voy a inventar mi propio universo.
CC comic, PC comic, lo que sea.
Agarraba a los chicos
en mi colegio que dibujaban y les decía
vamos a armar una movida,
te hago el guion, vos dibujá.
Iba a clase de dibujo
y le decía “Tirame una data”.
Vamos a armar un mundo.
Y se me cagaban un poco de risa,
pero bueno, era divertido.
Mi vieja una vez me llevó también
a una convención
para mi cumpleaños.
A una Comic Con, se llaman
las convenciones de cómic.
Mi vieja siempre me dejó que haga la mía,
me dejó ahí solo, encaré...
Llego, lo primero que me llamó mucho
la atención era de una sección que
estaban todos los dibujantes y los
guionistas pro haciendo autógrafos
tenías la fila larga y me daba un
poco de cosa hacer la fila larga porque
sentía una distancia en ese segundito
de acercarte a conseguir la firma.
Así que me quedé de un costado mirando
un toque, porque los admiraba.
Y me dio risa la diferencia,
tenías de este lado de las mesas
toda la gente esperando el autógrafo
y del otro estaban ellos laburando
metiéndole con todo,
haciendo un millón de firmas
y los hijitos a la vista.
Algunos andaban con los hijos,
fueron a mil Comic Con’es...
y me daba como risa la diferencia
de las energías
y decía estos fueron a mil Comic Con’es,
¡qué loco!
Entonces me fui a dar una vuelta
a la Comic-Con, que tiene de todo.
Increíble.
En un momento me cruzo a uno
de los hijos de los dibujantes.
Lo había reconocido, tenía mi edad,
así que le digo ¿qué onda guacho?
Tremendo lo que hace tu viejo,
bien ahí, pegamos la mejor.
Nos fuimos a ranchar, a dar una vuelta
por ahí, pegamos la mejor;
y después de un rato me dice si quería
ir al bar a conocer a su viejo,
y a los otros dibujantes.
Dije, de una, vamos.
En un tiro estaba ahí,
comiendo sanguchitos,
con todos.
Sí, con uno de Marvel que
había laburado en V de Vendetta
y estaba ahí en la salsa tirando bocetos.
Y yo no es que era un prodigio
que había mostrado un dibujo,
había encontrado mi manera
de meterme, ¿viste?
Y eso fue una experiencia muy linda.
Fue un gran aprendizaje también;
un aprendizaje que me ayudó mucho
en la próxima aventura que agarré,
que fue la música.
Yo me cambié un par
de años después de eso,
a un colegio público artístico.
Todos mis amigos músicos en ese colegio.
Empezamos a ranchear
mucho acá, en mi cuarto.
Yo ponía canciones de rap todo el día.
Ellos eran más del rock, ¿viste?
Les rapeaba todas las canciones
para que conozcan.
Decían, está bueno, está bueno.
Me la banco porque dentro de todo también
tenés ritmo cuando estás rapeando.
Deberías rapear tus propias cosas
en vez de cantar lo de los demás.
Mi amigo, que me dijo esto, era baterista
y yo lo admiraba mucho,
entonces como me lo dijo,
me puse a rapear mis propias
cositas de lo que sentía...
Empezó a crecer algo, una proyección
de a poco muy fuerte.
Empecé a ver entrevistas
también de raperos,
a ver qué onda, cómo había sido su vida,
cómo se habían pegado
y muchos hablaban en cositas en común
que era el lugar y el momento indicado.
Hablaban de desarrollar y grabar y estar
mucho encerrado desarrollando...
tu salsa.
Pero también una vez
que está eso desarrollado,
salir y manifestarlo y encontrarle...
Hablaban de hacérselo escuchar
a la gente indicada,
esas cosas y desde re guachín
iba al skate park y me llevaba
con todos los pro.
En el dibujo también siempre
encontré mi manera.
Digo, es esto, es grabar, sacarle
toda la salsa que tengo adentro
y después voy a encontrar el resto.
Uf, ahí mi proyección personal creció
un montón y empecé a grabar.
Y en Mar del Plata, en mi cuarto,
empecé a hacer mi primer disco.
Ni bien empecé, a los tres meses
de empezar a grabar,
empecé a hacer mi propio disco,
hice la instrumental.
Hice todas las producciones,
hice las voces, lo edité, hice la tapa,
lo subí a YouTube.
Aparte era todo en inglés.
Era medio loco, grababa en inglés
porque era lo que me gustaba,
dije, lo saco y va a pasar algo.
Y tuvo 10 visitas en el primer mes.
Yo estaba convencido, pero fue un
choque de realidad y la posta es que
entendí que no era solo sacarlo, grabarlo,
era la otra parte que también
me estaba dando cuenta.
Dije va a pasar, va a pasar.
Un día me llega un mensaje.
Un productor de Buenos Aires
que se había cruzado con mi música
y me dice te quiero presentar
a unos productores.
Tienen tu edad; sin darse cuenta,
me presentó a mi equipo de hoy en día.
La primera canción que grabamos juntos
evolucioné 5 años de calidad
porque eran chicos prodigio,
muy capos y yo hacía todo solo,
quemándome el bocho en mi casa, todo así.
Y ahí aprendí algo muy, muy copado que fue
delegar, delegar para poder trascender.
delegar para poder trascender.
Está bien, yo montaba en este cuarto,
pero había que ir a otros cuartos
y la unión hace la fuerza.
Grabamos como tres años y las conexiones
que yo estaba buscando,
no se estaban manifestando completamente
porque no había una movida
muy grande de hip hop en Argentina.
Entonces me fui a Bélgica a vivir;
nací allá, y mi papá estaba viviendo allá.
Llevé la compu nomás, un par
de utensilios, la mochila,
y me fui a vivir al altillo de mi viejo.
Y allá tenía un amigo que estaba metido
un poco en la movida de hip hop allá,
que era un poco más pro.
Él me tiraba todas la fiestas, todos los
fines de semana, todas las fiestas
de hip hop que había y yo encaraba todas
en bici, a veces hasta dos horas,
porque mi viejo vivía en el campo
y me llenaba los bolsillos con USBs.
Con 15 demos y mi Instagram; y con eso
encaraba y me metía a toda la fiestas.
Encontraba la manera de meterme al VIP,
o al backstage o a lo que sea
y encaraba a los raperos populares de ahí.
Yo los tenía junados y los encaraba.
Hola, me llamo Indra, acabo
de llegar de Argentina.
Grabo unas re datas,
por ahí te pinte grabar conmigo.
Podemos hacer unas re datas y estos
pibes en su salsa, en su fiesta,
yo llegaba, y se me cagaban de risa
la mayoría.
Pero yo sabía que uno por lo menos
por el encare...
Cuando sos artista, cuando te encara
un artista con hambre, te toca.
A mí me vienen, encaran así,
tengo que escucharlo sí o sí.
Yo sabía que alguno me iba a escuchar.
Volví a mi casa, después
de un par de días,
me llegó un mensajito.
Decía, che, estaban buenas las demos,
¿dónde grabas? En mi cuarto.
Venite un día.
Vino una vez, vino dos, vino tres.
Terminé produciéndole un disco
entero a ese chico.
Ese chico le contó a otro chico; grabé
otro disco entero para otro chico.
Ese le dijo a otro; terminé grabando
un par de discos allá;
tuve hasta un disco de oro
siendo ingeniero, grabando
para otros artistas.
Y eso fue un lapso de ocho meses
desde que llegué hasta que estaba ahí.
Con mucha hambre, y en paralelo a mi
crecimiento en en Bélgica, mis colegas
amigos de acá de Buenos Aires, que yo
había conectado de los años anteriores,
empezaron a producir
a los que hacían freestyle.
Acá había una movida
muy grande de freestyle,
que no es lo mismo que grabar canciones.
Y cuando se fusionó este mundo
de la superproducción...
Mis amigos y los free-stylers...
explotó acá la movida de hip hop.
Una revolución en Argentina.
Muy fuerte la música por esa fusión.
Yo me había ido justo a Bélgica.
Menos de un año, y decía, no puede ser,
el destino me está pinchando,
no había movida, estuve tres años
tratando de clavar una movida allá
y me voy al otro lado del mundo.
Bueno, el mundo te va pinchando,
a ver qué tanto querés materializar.
Así que en el altillo, en Bélgica,
empecé a grabar en español,
algo que nunca había hecho,
siempre había grabado todo en inglés,
mi trip era en inglés.
Escuchaba raperos en inglés...
Me cayó la proyección de cómo voy
a hacer que me escuche gente
que no conozco...
Es haciendo con estos chicos grandes
que los producen mis amigos, ¿viste?
Entonces hice 3, 5, 10, 15,
30 canciones en español.
Las mandé.
Y una eligió Duki, una la eligió Cazzu,
una eligió Ecko.
Eran chicos muy grandes.
Tenía cien seguidores viviendo un altillo
con canciones, con chicos que tenían
millones de seguidores.
Así que lo preparamos.
Vimos cómo sacarlo.
Y sacamos este, primero.
Somos estrellitas de rock
Vale millones mi voz
Tu flow pa’ mí que es precoz
Tengo salsita pa’ vos
Después de un tiempito sacamos este.
Yoh, ja, ja
Y cinco días después de sacar
el anterior, sacamos este.
Besa’ Bésame, mi amor
No sé cuanto tiempo me voy
Aprovechemos el hoy porque es hoy
Porque es hoy
Y bueno, estas tres canciones se llaman:
Mojaa con el Ducko, Piso con Ecko,
Bésame con Seven Kayne,
y me cambiaron la vida.
Tuvieron todas más de 10 millones
de visitas cada una.
Fue algo muy fuerte y se había
materializado esta cosa
que tanto había buscado durante...
Habían pasado cinco años...
Cuando pasa una cosa así muy fuerte
y pasan dos, pasan tres.
Un par de días después de sacar el último
de los tres, se muere mi abuelo.
Allá en Bélgica.
Y al otro día que se muere mi abuelo,
me llaman de Argentina, me dicen:
Che, tenés una gira entera
y vas a tocar por todos lados.
Y el remate de todo,
¿cuándo empieza la gira?
El día del velorio de mi abuelo.
Entonces, tenía que decidir
o ir al velorio o empezar la gira.
Y me fui de gira, hice la gira,
mi familia en ese momento se enojó.
Pero no entendían esta cosa también
de los números, que había pasado
de tener 100 seguidores a 100 000
seguidores propios, en un mes.
Gente me empezaba a seguir.
Pensaban que era un hack,
que había puesto números.
No, era gente de verdad, pero bueno, lo
logramos y fue todo un desarrollo de acá
en el cuarto de la casa de mi mamá.
Después me fui al altillo de mi viejo.
Pero además de todo este laburo
de cientos de canciones,
fue encontrarle un lugar allá
y salir y encarar el mundo para
encontrarle un lugar a tus cosas
en el mundo, porque si no solo
sos un loco, un loco que hace cosas.
Y hay una diferencia entre un loco
y alguien que encuentra
su locura en el mundo.
Así que bueno, esta fue mi historia y les
deseo muchísima suerte con la suya.
Muchísimas gracias.